economics talks personally by adjustment
Lee who's from the Turkish universities
and it talked about doing theory alright
thank you I'll before inviting me over
so so Abby told me that he wants me to
talk give us an overview about economics
in blockchain and and with some focus on
my own work so I look into my own papers
and I've realized that there's a common
theme that is game theory so I think
what I'm gonna do today is right I'm
trying to do the kind of an impossible
try to put three papers together and try
to frame them in and arrange in my in a
nice way so that I can finish the autumn
all of them in 15 minutes so just kind
of give you an overview about all the
three papers I'm going to be talking
about so by the way the first paper
actually some of you may have already
seen that last month one of my co-author
also presented this paper at at this
conference so you may be able to access
the video so I'm gonna be very short on
the first paper but that's actually
going to be some game theory and now
it's into the mining poles and the
mining industry and then I'm gonna focus
on the other other paper is looking at
some game theory analysis into initial
corn offering so we're trying to provide
an economic theory for us to understand
what is the value created by crypto
tokens especially what they call
so-called utility tokens and the last
paper that I'm going to be talking about
is also kind of a game theory and the
paper would not originally ride the
paper I didn't really wrote it for crit
buffer blockchain right I was thinking
at the time was thinking about like
investment crowdfunding but as time goes
by I realized okay think about what the
initial coin offering is it's basically
kind of doing a crowdfunding on the
blockchain so it kind of has the app
implications toward blockchain 2 and
also it's going to be about an
investment problem so it may also have
some kind of implications and guidance
for us to design that decentralized
autonomous organizations so I'm a
hopefully I'm gonna get through all of
them within the next 15 minutes if we
have extra time I'm gonna just talk a
little bit about some of our recent
thoughts on using
applying game theory to consensus
protocols but maybe we're not gonna be
able to get there all right so just very
quickly mining pools mining pools in the
mining industry so what are the I'm
assuming everybody here in the room
right knows what mining pools are so
just show some facts here what we plot
is
over time the evolution of this mining
industry so this that this is horizontal
line is time it starts from we our
sample starts from 2011 and ends until
the end of 2018 so you can see all these
like mountain like blocks these are
basic mining quotes but it shows the
evolution of the market share of each
different mining poles and the big red
associated a big white chunk here are
independent miners so back in the early
days most of mining are done by
competitive individual miners that are
not part of a pool as Satoshi Nakamoto
envisioned in its white paper over time
we see that the market has become
completely dominated by a mining course
is it one thing second is that mining
poles do gets large some time but also
come gets small over time it doesn't
seem to be that over time there's a
strong tendency for one particular
mining pole to dominate the entire
market and a third is this line here
this actually is the log version of the
total computing power the total hash
rates compute that devoted into Bitcoin
mining and overall it's on an upward
trend so what our paper is trying to do
we try trying to build a theory using
economic insights to explain all the
facts that we can observe from this part
this this chart namely first
why do mining pools arise in the first
place second if mining pools have reason
to arise why there is no such a force
that pushes one particular mining pool
to become dominant right third the rise
of those mining pools in the evolution
of the market share of those mined
impose whether it has anything to do
with the increasing hash rate and
devoted into Bitcoin money
so this is our plan I'm gonna be very
quick on this paper I'm gonna get rid of
all the math because my court has done
that but I just give you some intuitions
so this green line for example showed
like the green bubble at the beginning
that's a budding poll that survived and
then basically evaporated oh yeah so
basically there's this poor basic died
over here all the people who were part
of that who presumably joined another
pool yes
oh this is just like we collect all the
data from Bitcoin comm so you can't you
can have the block really information
and then just every month where you just
look at how many blocks are produced
over what how many blocks should be
produced globally and you can get the
kind of get an estimate of the weight
but then so could the weight part
include mining pools that don't
advertise themselves they actually could
yes that's that's very possible
so first of all why do you mining pools
arise in the first place I don't think
the I think this is just common
knowledge or everybody probably knows
about this because mining is risky so
joining a pool can reduce your risk
that's just income smoothing everybody
knows that you don't need me to tell you
so if you're a small minor you want to
join a mining pool second question why
people may think that a large pool will
ever get larger so leads to
concentration implications this is
because if mining pools is for risk
sharing you are the miner here when
you're faced with a small pool versus
with a large pool you can think about
which pool provides you with better risk
sharing and I think it should be pretty
obvious that the large pool provides you
better assuring if based on that insight
we may just draw the conclusion that if
a pool that starts being large will
attract more miners and that the pool
which has become even larger then
eventually become an awfully and
dominate the entire mining space and
that creates there kind of destroys all
the purpose have all these
decentralization
this gets a little bit complicated right
because pools may also charge fees so
when you join a pool you don't get the
whole you don't get their fair share
actually that there's a percentage of
them actually goes to a pool operator so
the tip the question is now becomes like
saying okay if you have a large pool
versus a small pool but the large post
imposed a is supposed to a charge is a
higher fee now what is what should be
your decision whether you join a large
pool with a higher fee or a small pool
with a smaller fee that's kind of a kind
of a tough question for financial
economists yes the application it could
be private quote but you can think about
private pools just more like a miner
that participates in the remaining space
rather than so when we talk about the
pools here you can think about all of
them are open pools
say giant miner that has just a large
fraction well so not in the data no but
in theory our analysis shouldn't should
apply to pose or to minors of any any
size suppose like if this is like for
example here's a private pool then you
can think about this is that maybe like
a large part they pull over here you
just think about it as a same individual
minor
so there's a feed there's also like a an
algorithm for the share for the block
reward sharing right right they are not
all proportional to they're like the
partial non partial solution that you
provide but the goal right all the the
goal is trying to approximate that your
share of the hash rates among all the
participants so for our analysis we just
assumed that this part right this
algorithm is perfect right so like we
can measure your your share of the patch
rates among all the pool members
perfectly yeah so you're saying
empirically this is how pools charge
we're laying out priori you can imagine
the pool that says look you pay us like
ten thousand dollars up front and you
can mine with us for the year so like
the pricing would be like not really
comparably they really like you know you
wouldn't know what the price of bitcoins
gonna be in six months but you know how
much you paid to participate in this
mining pool but you're just saying we're
rolling that out because empirically it
doesn't happen everybody just the pool
just takes some fraction of the bit so
there are two answers to this first is
that or we actually have some empirical
data actually how do you collect pool in
for a poofy information that's one part
of it and also in our modeling framework
later on we'll have also we call so
called passive miners who do not
actually optimally allocate your hash
rates so you can think about it by for
example I have a long-term contract with
a particular mining pool that I'm gonna
be skate sticking to your pool for a
year that will be an hour model they
captured eyes like city passive miner
that stick with them so this exercise
right it doesn't really have a clear-cut
answer but it's actually very easy for
financial economist but when we think of
as financial economist when we think
about the stock market all we talk about
is okay when I invest in the stock is
about the return versus risk trade-off
so here when you think about you are
joining a pool the fee that they charge
and the risk sharing benefit that a the
pool can provide you exactly that frame
is exactly that framework so and also if
any of you have been thinking about this
problem if you think that I should join
this pool or if you think about that I
should actually join this pool then
unfortunately you got it wrong
because I also just according to
financial economics what we learn know
what we learn is that when you face
these two poles what you should do
is that versified don't put all your
eggs in one basket so if you are a minor
in your face multiple poles that charge
different fees and of different sizes
then you should allocate your hash hash
rights right just according to you an
optimal ratio across these all different
poles yes just why would why would the
mining pool operators want this
but what mining pool operator cannot
prevent you from doing this no but they
can do they can do the frequent-flyer
thing where we apply these like highly
nonlinear rewards to try to like
basically monopolize the customer or I
guess in this case the miner and so I'm
just surprised that people aren't
playing like these more sophisticated
policies to try to like basically you
know gobble up as many miners as
possible to get more powering
marketplace to be able to get because
because like the some for most apart the
the the identity of these miners are
kind of anonymous to the mining pools
and you can simply think about their I
mean there's no reason there's no way to
prevent a miner from doing some civil
attack type of response to whatever
schedules that is post that abided by a
mining poles if you actually have a
longer-term relationship you get like a
higher yes that's right that's that
asset yeah the second part then is going
to be again just like we assume that
your is going to be some passive finders
who do just stick to a pool later later
on later on during the model like say my
name more than X in here there's going
to be miners who don't have the capacity
to mine X in a year so they'll say if I
join this pool I'm subsidizing bigger
players than me and then they're just
gonna go to the pool that doesn't have
the frequent flyer program unless it's
cheaper even with the frequent flyer
that that's all that's I've all valid
valid points and the way we accommodate
that is going to be some miners would
not be like optimal allocating their
hash rates according to what we're going
to prescribe for these other reasons
maybe it's the actually what they are
doing is actually optimal they are not
optimal in our model but we can
accommodate them
okay so the idea is that you should
actually allocate to both poles in your
diverse spot because both poles the
poles are going to be solving
independent questions if you allocate
hash rates across poles you're going to
be having further diversification
benefit so just as a kind of a side note
so one of my some of my colleagues in
the computer science department we
actually implemented a we actually
implemented a a website so you can go on
to this website and like you just to
choose okay I want to mine Bitcoin and
these are the number of poles that I
want to participate and this is my
number of my hash rates and also specify
how risk-averse you are then basically
that algorithm will just pop out okay
how much hash we should be allocated for
and poll how much should be after you
have to pool how much should be somehow
the way the risk is it takes a long time
but practicing if you have a pool that
you're big enough then it goes down
exponentially so it's not like you're
guaranteed basically and there's some
many little differences but then I
shouldn't care if the pool is much much
bigger than that well not not exact not
exactly like that because when you are a
very large pool and also there is a lot
of money at stake so eventually like
from the tip of the standard way of
think about your preference or utility
is going to be defined over your
eventual wealth right so you can think
about okay so if I have a if I can pull
a lot of random sources so maybe by law
of large numbers in terms of the just
there the randomness is become smaller
but I still I have a lot of money at
stake so I'm that the small random
there's multiplied by the large money
that I state is still going to be large
becomes negligible if this the wealth
becomes so large right so then the
multiplication of them is still going to
not going to be in
so yeah so so this risk aversion just
mean like shape of utility curve weather
yes yes yes all right so so far what we
have introduced is okay think about what
how miners would should allocate clear
hash rate or how they should do
decisions when they face port but now
here's the game theory part that comes
in pools they can expect that miners
will be optimally allocating their hash
rates across different pools and also
some of them maybe not for whatever
reason that we have just discussed right
so so let's think about okay if what if
the schools they engage in a competition
by just deciding how much the fee that
they charge right so music it's a Nash
what we want analyzed is a Nash
equilibrium each full each pool takes
into account what other pools are
charging and what current size they are
running and decide on what is the
optimal fee that I want to charge so and
because of some miners may not be
optimally allocating hash rates at all
times so that basically will make the
game become a Bertrand competition
amount of holes but the goods that their
pools provides not become imperfect
substitutes
when the pools are deciding what the
fees that they charge they need to think
about three things the first is that the
revenue from those so called passive
miners right because if I increase my
feet those these guys already have a
long-term contract with me they stick
with me if I increase the fees I'm gonna
get more from these cuts but also I need
to think about the the participation
from active miners because if I charge a
high fee then the active miners are not
some of the active matter is just gonna
be go away from my PO and they just go
to some other pools okay so I also need
to think about that and there's a third
is that my externality or the mining
difficulty because if I if I'm a large
pool in a charge a very high fee that is
going to deter miners from joining the
mining game in general and the probably
is going to have some impact on the
mining difficulty so that's my
externality on the on the mining
difficulty and expect that if a pool
that with more kind of passive miners
will have larger externality so when
they decide on their fees they also need
to internalize that externality
so so just give you the without going to
authority analysis if you solve the game
what we can find that maybe seem quite
intuitive if the pool that starts being
large that who that that has a lot of
miners and a lot of hash words that
stick with them when we solve the game
will we will find that optimal for them
to charge higher fees so and previously
there is one one thing that I'm that I'm
didn't mention is that when the our
miners are deciding how to allocate
their hash rate if two pools charge the
same fee then the optimal allocation for
you would be suppose that this pole is
twice the size of this pole and they
charge the same amount of fee they the
optimal allocation for you as a miner is
going to divide your hash rates into
three pieces and you have two pieces
going here and one piece is going in
here it's another word for poles that
charge the same fee the optimal
allocation for you is always it should
be proportional and if one of the poles
charge a little bit higher fees than the
other then you can use this proportional
allocation as a benchmark until toward
the pool that charge a little bit lower
fee you just balance the expected value
from each pole like this but the
expected utility so you to take the risk
and the return and the risk and trick
account that's also why in this in this
demo right so your risk aversion plays a
role so acid miners are what lead to
different fees in different pool
structures because exactly exactly
actually like we if we did I put it here
maybe I didn't so like if if we think
about it a benchmark case if there's no
passive miners at all then the out game
outcome would be all the pools were
charged zero fees because it's a better
on competition race to the bottom
everybody charges zero fees and pool
size doesn't matter because no matter
what the size distributions are as an
active manner you're just going to
allocate proportional so so this is kind
of what you mentioned this kind of
friction is actually important for
driving some of the results so large
codes will charge higher fees and
because they charge higher fees
miners allocate proportionally less hash
rates to them that so that that's why
the
cause Apple actually grows slower and
this is why we found that in the data
that there seems to be a mean reverting
force that prevents one polls from being
getting too large so this is a
decentralization force so last point we
want to talk about okay how does the
rise of mining polls get associated with
the increase of hash rates you can think
about well the first-order effect must
be like escalating like a six you are
just the improvement in the AMD in
hardware but we think there is also
another very important reason and it's
also very intuitive so suppose that you
are a minor if you mind alone suppose
this is the optimal amount of hash rate
that you want to devote to mining right
when you're deciding how much hash were
you devote into mining you need to think
about the cost of mining and also think
about need to think about the return and
the risk associated with doing the
mining but now suppose that you join a
money oops now suppose you join a mining
poor and mining pool provides you risk
sharing so now that you perceive the
risk that your face to be lower if you
don't adjust this amount of hash rates
that you devote your mining but because
if you have a given risk bearing
capacity once you join a mining pool
you'll find it's actually optimal for
you right to allocate more hash rates
into mining because mani now becomes
less risky
from your perspective if we think about
all the miners doing the same thing if
all the miners now they join mining
pools they all will find it's optimal
for them just to ask to allocate more
hash rates into mining but we know that
mining basic is a zero-sum game because
this difficulty adjustment process so
like that's why like we see my burning
holes arise and associated associated
with that we can see an increase in the
hash rate that the total hash rates
devoted to mining and actually we did
some calculation we find that like given
reasonable parameters having mining
pools versus not having mining pools can
actually ask can be multiplied the total
global hash rates devoted to money by
almost ten times
so hopefully just I didn't go through
the details of the paper but hopefully I
can I could give you the gist of all the
insights that we explained why we see my
nipples arise why we don't see mine
impose monopolize and why we see an
increase in hash rate Oh within our
framework yes so in the model with
static minors they are gonna stick with
that pool no matter what the charges and
the chuffin no matter how high it is yes
pay that char yes yes I mean a real life
they're under Lake 24-month contract
yeah yeah you can think about the model
is always simplification a cap kind of
captures that idea yes yeah but then
given this model it could be that many
of these pools are actually the same
right because my incentive is a mining
pool operator would be to jack up the
prices to like basically gouge my static
planners as much as possible so then I
should just create a new brand that I
can use to like get a miners who wanted
like a lower fee and then hope so in the
paper we have a we have a section
talking about the like entry of new
pools and I think we don't have time to
talk about this but we can every go but
do you see some evidence that
essentially it's the same pool that's
just rebranding with a different fee
structure and then yes it does happen I
think one of I forgot the name I think
how BTC used to be what name I don't
remember the details but and those lines
compressing right there's like see in
the middle section from October 15th to
2015 and then they just get thinner and
thinner as you move to the right are
those basically like static in the sense
that they have the same hash power but
the market like the market just saw this
is all market share so if we talk about
absolute hash for it's probably it's
gonna be I have like let's say ten
percentage points of the of the market
share in 2016 but no new people join my
pool and but the whole market is
increasing presumably my share it gets
smaller and smaller yeah yeah so
actually I didn't put it
actually we have the empirical data that
just basically run the regressions about
their pool growth and pull fees on their
initial size and we basically find to
this result that is consistent with our
daily prediction so the logical charge
higher fees and they go slow
I guess from this graph it looks to me
like there's just so much activity like
new new pools coming into the situation
to play situation all the time like how
are they marketing themselves how are
they differentiating themselves like
this is a commodity right so why
wouldn't there be a first bit of
advantage that like 10 people started in
2012 and those are the 10 that stick
around some of the Vantage you you do
have is like easier if there are already
a lot of hash rates that are sticking to
you like passive hash rate stick to you
then you can think about your kind of
magnets that attract a lot of other
people because you know that from miners
perspective you joined this pool and
here are some people who just are not
gonna move around you have some people
to shoulder the risk along with you so
you can think about that is one
advantage but the there's no kind of
mechanical first mover advantage other
than this suppose I figure you are very
big pool today but for whatever reason
like all these passive hash rates all
the act active hash rates just migrate
overnight to another path another poor
people just dies there's nothing that
prevents you that kind of like
mechanical in the in a technology that
makes a particular cool okay but there's
nothing that's suggested people if your
model suggests people are really stinky
and I'm not suggesting I'm just making
that as a stomp sure yeah this green
trunk starting in like October 16th what
like how that went from one percentage
point to like you know 15 percentage
points of the market like I'm looking to
the data to tell exactly particularly is
there some story that like how these
things start and stay successful yeah
five years of other pools so in the
paper we have some anecdotal evidence
it's like showing okay how a pool is
initiated and some of the you can
basically like subpar from the old early
pools you can just go back to your
Bitcoin talk right so like they would
tell they busy market there okay I
devised design a pool actually I think
the sludge quality the the crater
actually always goes on months of
discussions with the community how
should I actually design the pool yeah
yeah but the things that if these things
are happening and
is something given when a new pool comes
they've got some novel marketing
strategy or pricing strategy yeah if
your model doesn't leave room for
innovation in the pricing strategy and
tracking you well the model the model is
not trying to explain everything right
that this is the reality the model is
just trying to capture some of the most
the first-order effect right so I mean
if Naugle I try to explain to you in the
model in a very simple way I mean look
at the math you're just like it
according to the model why wouldn't you
mining pool come into existence
just because someone gets lucky it's a
small so one reason could be like which
we didn't talk about like for example
they may be just Bitcoin price goes up
right so maybe means just like the
mining industry now it just becomes
larger it's it becomes a larger market
so people want to join so there's a lot
of reasons which we had we don't
consider in the paper and intentionally
people destroying an existing way
we can do that too I'm not I'm not
saying that's not happening with a
possible reason within your model why a
new mining pool like that green one on
the website might come into existence
and suddenly get large this is a very
good explanation very often you just
have a large miner that wants to buy his
Apple so he sets up his own operation he
doesn't want to pay fees of 1% or
whatever to somebody else I see and then
he opens the once he has the
infrastructure he opens it up to others
yeah yeah yes so actually so the main
difference that we look at is like
between those local PTAs poles versus
other type of rewarding schemes because
although what type of rewarding schemes
eventually would like to take just up
try to approximate your share of your
hash rates right as close as possible
pay per share so that's kind of fixed
wage righteous like as long as you're at
you are generating partial solutions I'm
just giving you a constant money
regardless whether the poll finds or not
so ours our our I so our theory applies
the best to the proportional
it's very hard like once you have a big
pool to change the reward structure out
from under the people because they all
sort of say oh we signed up under and
it's one formula and now you want to
change it so every time someone comes up
with any new wrinkle on you know like
randomize the LMS or whatever it has to
like come into existence via a new pool
rather than like changing an existing
pool so there's like a lot of rooms will
be able to say like oh we can't we don't
have this item or fare well I'm I mean
in terms of technology just technically
wise it's not difficult but just like
whether it's an optimal solution from
the pools perspective it may be another
story because you don't just you you
want to have some stability in your
clothes operation okay are we good to
move on to the next paper okay good
thanks for all the other comments so
yeah so the next paper is we gonna be
talking about initial current offerings
so also just assuming when I present
this to Finance audience I need to go
through a length about talking about the
background of initial core offerings and
tokens but I think for this audience
it's really not necessary so we not
understand what tokens are so when when
I begin to look into the the tokens in
ICS when I thought okay well some of the
kind of most exemplary most examples
right if you're in file coin and what
you're trying to do they're basically
trying to facilitate or decentralize the
platform and what our I think a defining
feature of this decentralized platform
is that your so-called network effect
the by they're basically cuz they're
facilitating trades between buyers and
sellers the buyers cares about the
sellers presence and the sellers cares
about the fires presence so in the
community we sometimes called a
chicken-and-egg problem if you don't
have the buyer how could you attract the
seller if you already have the buyer
then you automatically have this out and
it using economic terms right it's
basically just so-called a coordination
game in any type of coordination games
there used to be multiple Nash
equilibria there could be a good
equilibrium everybody joins and enjoy
the benefits of the platform or a bad
equilibrium or you can call their
coordination failure just because people
believing that other side is not going
to be joining I choose not to join to
and if you think about if you're any
startup trying to launch a such a
platform you always start from this
failure there is no existing customers
to your to our platform in the first
place so our idea is that whether tokens
what could be a way to jumpstart a
platform to avoid us to to avoid us
getting stuck in this coordination
failure stage and so we can move on to a
like a good outcome good coordination
outcome so this is what we try to do in
this paper so in order to do that we
design a very simple model to describe
the operation of a platform so of course
again just for the sake of a model right
you can think about you can talk about a
lot of real realistic details that need
to enter into the model but it's made to
be simple in intentionally so there is a
there's a demand side and the supply
side of a platform operation and every
day there are going to be too few users
ice are there gonna be one user on each
side that is showing up right we just
call them Alice and Bob so the way we
model this is that today alice is going
to be demanding the service and tomorrow
address is going to be supplying the
service and then just we alternate
between dates and the day just runs and
the timeline just runs forever and for
anyone who is on the demand side if you
get a service that is fulfilled then
today you will get a surplus which we
call s and if you provide the service to
the other side today then you you incur
a cost which we call the C and some and
also we assume that you're some utility
cost you for you just to participate in
this in this platform
I just regardless of whether you get
your service it fulfilled or whether you
actually provide the service or not as
long as you participate for one day you
just need to pay that utility positive
in fearsome and we have a discount rate
the usual assumption is that but if
coordination is successful
this platform generates value to the
users pressure this condition holds
if this condition doesn't hold then this
platform if essentially is a [ __ ] coin
that we just should not be talked about
anyway
but even if this crowd project is
valuable even this even if this
condition holds because of this
participation cost if Alice does not
expect Bob to show up today Alice will
also choose not to show up so even if a
potentially useful product or platform
may still be have coordination failure
because it of this coordination defect
okay
so how do we solve this model and I'm
not intending to you have very to read
it but just like just give you an idea
this is actually going to be the
solution concept and what we're going to
be using is going to be some idea called
the weekly sequential equilibrium and
refined by for an induction I'm gonna
give them explain them in detail later
so this usually use sequential
equilibrium for games with imperfect
information yes what secret does that
listen Bob have about them whether they
are going to join or not so there so the
types of Alice are like the days on
which they're going to be aspired the
days in which they're going to be oh
this is this this is this is known to
that everybody knows that okay today is
Alice aspire
tomorrow Bob Bob is the buyer then
Alice's buyer Bobby's bar this is
commonly known what is unknown as the
game evolved is that from Bob's
perspective I don't know whether Alice
actually
Alice is on demand side today but
whether she is really gonna hop on the
platform actually demand a service this
is unknown to Bob same for Alice
but as Alice doesn't know Attis note
that bob is a potential service provider
but whether he truly provides the
service or not that's a no but their
prices at which the supply demand price
is essentially which are what the
uncertainties about no it's about
whether that their day the existence of
the quantity rather the existence of the
supply and the demand is conserved okay
right is that is that clear like nothing
blocking specific so far so far I'm just
talking about the platform operation I'm
just modeling the platform operation now
later on I'm gonna say okay how does
token plays our role here right so now
that she's just to set a benchmark right
so I'm critical of American look at okay
what if this platform just use daughters
maybe just like eBay right Alice use
dollars if Alice want to buy the service
and I space daughters and see what's
gonna happen and then later on we'd say
okay what if we change these daughters
into tokens and see what's gonna happen
and it result of course is going to be
as expected or I should be different
otherwise if there is no way for us to
write the paper so okay so okay so now
let's look at okay Addis to Addis use
dollars to Edna's can use daughters to
buy the service from Bob let's see
whether this coordination problem is
still gonna persist so in ideal case
that is peasant Bob the money and the
service is conducted them then Alice as
are these Alice is happy the question is
from Bob's perspective that comes to
your question about the uncertainty
right what's the imperfect information
Bob doesn't really know what actions
addicts Attis is truly gonna take at it
whether whether at is first of all
whether Alice has some of the money or
not right maybe Maddox just doesn't
really have the money if that it doesn't
have the money then I would not be able
to when I provide the service there's
nobody actually gonna be buying the
service as a bob should be worried about
this second is like even Bob is sure
that Alice can does have the money
you're still the concern is because the
ballot the money can the US dollars can
be used outside of the platform and is
having a pile of banknotes in her pocket
doesn't necessarily mean that she's
actually gonna spend that amount of
money within this platform so Bob still
left the worried about okay whether at
is actually going to participate or not
again it becomes a coordination problem
so the coordination problem cannot
really be solved by using dollars as a
payment method within a platform economy
so now let's take as you can expect
right now let's look at what if we
replace dollars with tokens so because
dollars have like some substitute you
can buy substitute goods with those
dollars outside use of money you have
outside use of money and also there's no
transparency about your ownership of of
daughter so - so two concerns from Bob's
perspective whether you have money or
not even if you have money
oops even you have money you may be
spending somewhere else so bob is not
certain whether address is going to be
demanding the service so he it makes
hard for him to decide whether I watch
actually want to provide the service or
not
now that I look at token right token has
two features I'm not saying that's the
universal across all tokens but at least
for a lot of tokens it does have this
feature first is that the ownership of
token is very transparent you can look
up the you can look up the blockchain
and figure out okay the whether Alice
has token or not
second the a lot of tokens right there
design specific specifically for a
platform so so if Bob can know that
Alice has the token Bob knows that the
token cannot really be used anywhere
else so the transparency of the
blockchain makes the ownership of token
certain to Bob and also the token
doesn't really have any outside use with
outside of the platform that makes sure
that Bob's is okay if Alice has a token
if she wants to use it she has to use it
to me so it increases the confidence for
Bob that okay actually we are I'm going
to expect a coordination success yeah so
actually it should be it actually it
should become for ended within this
model it would be that within this stage
on the equilibrium path whoever owns the
but the token should be the buyer if
you're not a buyer you actually there
shouldn't be any reason for you to own
the token yet this will become clear
once I introduce icos because I haven't
taught by zero so now I just assumed
that this token just magically exists
but then the question is like for those
who buy the thank you for your fair
selling the token to me and they think
about why I want to buy the token and I
probably presumably I want to use the
service later right because otherwise
why would I buy buy it from you alive by
just there could be a chain of
transactions but the last buyer should
be able to be willing to spend this
kotoba on the platform because otherwise
otherwise maybe what there's one
possibility that otherwise they're just
a perpetual bubble which we think about
is bubble can exist in the short run but
we don't think that there should be a
perpetual
that's what's happened so far right well
yeah we are not in perpetual yet how
many years for somebody offering the
same service for government service
weird yeah yeah yeah yeah so that you're
talking about the previous slides right
just like your daughters have outside
uses but it could be but like but like
if you we have the suppose that you're
to suppose they're there to two
platforms that provides the same service
but this token like we're talking about
platform one and that token that Alice
has is the pokken that can be used in
platform one even though Alice once you
use the same Alice can get potentially
get the same service in from platform 2
she doesn't really have the token from
platform 2
okay so we haven't talked about I see
OHS yet right you think about what is
ICO we just mentioned the token and the
token just coming out of thin air but we
know that when a token is created it has
to be distributed to the users in the
first place and this it typically
happens before the platform starts
operation and we can think about that as
an ICO right so we just moved up the
timeline one slot ahead and add a
previous stage before the entire
platform operation starts and this is a
time when ICO happens and what does ICO
do ICO Alice comes up with some money or
not necessary the US dollar here it
could be Bitcoin if there or US dollars
just sum of money that is not intrinsic
to this platform yet and I spent some
real resources and exchanged that into
token and then she can carry the token
to the next period and then the game
just operates as what we have just
described earlier so okay now you think
about what does Alice what is adding
this ICO stage actually does for all the
other players here so from at Bob bobs
perspective he can transparently observe
Alice ownership of the token and he also
knows that the token doesn't really have
any use outside of this platform so by
observing at is having token today on
the first day of the platform operation
Bob what Bob can infer is that Alice has
taken some very costly action that is
spending real resources and buying into
something that doesn't have anything is
outside of this platform what does this
tell Bob if Bob believed that alice is a
rational person then Bob should infer
that Alice will in be intending to use
this token if Alice do not ever intend
to use this token it will be silly for
Alice to spend real resources into
buying into buy buy into this token so
this is kind of a way at least we can
kind of resolve the coordination problem
whether the first stage and this is what
our previous mentioned is like when we
use this weekly sequential equilibrium
as a solution concept and they type the
line of argument that I have just talked
about is actually what we call a forward
forward induction
refinement of game outcomes support
induction basically means that in a
dynamic game when he can observe some
other players past behaviors and
especially if they take some behaviors
that kind of look stupid
you should infer that it tells reveal
some information about their future
actions like some of the seemingly
stupid actions that have taken in the
past probably should you should tell you
that it's part of a grand strategy of
this entire game which supposed to be
good for for that player right this
basically is based on the assumption
that you believe that the other side is
rational so some of these people are may
not necessary be rational right so and
like if you believe by in token is gonna
give me a key to give you a lot of money
we can look at the performance of 90% of
the tokens right so this does build on a
strong assumption that everybody
believed in each other just in typical
game theory you believe that everybody
is gonna be rational if some people are
irrational then when you just need to
wait for the market to mature so they
kind of balancing between the appeal of
them as a speculative asset because
that's what kind of gets you over that
initial huh that's what against these
coins out there you know they buy one of
these tokens they're not there's nothing
to use it on yet usually you're pointing
out is that if you go too far in that
direction then nobody's ever gonna use
them yeah so I I think a currently I
think you give a very kind of precise
kind of description about the current
status quo what my hope is that as
people understand this theory better I
hope that eventually people will see
that actually what the value comes or
what the value of a token that really
have is actually coming from its usage
when the platform rather than this
speculation part well actually that
speculation
part may actually hurt you so we have to
assume we have to admit that currently
in the market not all players are
rational not because they are stupid
because we're just this is a new concept
we're still learning about it yes that's
like security tokens like yeah yeah like
security token we have both yes so
there's if we think about it they think
about more complicated problems there's
a more comprehensive problem right that
we need to think about okay the tokens
can play this role here and maybe also
have the security role and whether it's
a good idea to combine them together or
maybe like some some project they do
they kind of have separate tokens I'm
tokens to be treated your security token
and some tokens which is meant to be a
utility that that's kind of another
discussion that we can build on what we
have learned so so this is the idea of
so called forward induction I sometimes
when I talk to lay people I say okay
what do you how do you can you
understand this right how would I like
why does taking some bad actions in a
pass may actually signal some good
actions in the in the future some
examples I give people is like look at
when why when a man proposed to a woman
he gives him a ring a diamond ring from
my perspective a diamond ring is
expensive and it's completely useless
and it's very costly for the men to take
that action
so if from the woman's perspective okay
you take a kind of stupid action but
it's we know that's not super stupid
right because you are taking a costly
action then you signal to the other
person yeah I truly love you that's why
I give you that I'm willing to spend
those money and on something that's
completely useless
I actually serve that role I don't know
how well that like that place are you a
future slide explain the equilibrium the
equilibrium would be under this forward
induction refinement that the solution
will be Alice buys the token
participates and the unique equilibrium
would be so that satisfy for
introduction at is participants IC o----
has the token and both parties will
always just join the platform as the
platform operates
and the reason is because Bob knows no
okay Alice has taken some costly action
and it would be unwise for her to not
spend the token like in a sequential
equilibrium you also have to have
beliefs about everybody else yes yes
deduction part only to justify the
beliefs that participation by the board
induction basically is a restriction a
refinement on the belief so my belief is
that if I saw your past actions I would
infer that it signals what you're going
to do in the future because you I'm
gonna rule out any future actions that
when combined with your past action
looks kind of silly from your sight for
the entire game so I can I can see your
seemingly city actions until today but
that tells me okay this must be part of
some smart strategies I mean given that
I spend dollars on the first day are you
saying you cannot commit you cannot
commit because the dollars can be used
at any other places and also dollars do
it doesn't really have this transparency
I don't know how much money you have but
I think I can observe how many tokens
you have so you're saying this doesn't
work in a in a currency like like an
anonymous sort of privacy friendly
currency like Zee cash in the current
framework no and whether it can be
accommodated at I did not need to be
virtual research but based on what I
have now then the answer is no the
Transpo the transparency and the the
fact that it doesn't really have any use
outside other other platform outside of
this platform are important for the
result
okay you have a Tokyo utility token you
can use it in the platform you can use
for anything else look at the
cryptocurrency that it's not a utility
token then it looks like exactly the
same except there's no platform that you
feel like you can use for anything but
it still has value so why doesn't this
somehow this analysis should hold then
Bitcoin should be with zero so I mean
I'm here providing a theory of
explaining why some tokens can have
value it doesn't preclude other theories
of explaining like so there could be
other theories for expanding the value
of Bitcoin so it also depends on how you
actually define what's the scope of the
system because you can think about I
mean compared to dollar right Bitcoin
still have very limited use compared to
the platform Bitcoin as very general use
so I mean the model is kind of generic
and up riding it I didn't really specify
how what's the scope of this right you
can think about what type of service
that Alice and Bob can provide to each
other if it's very restricted then it
could be a specific platform if it's
less a little bit more general every
dollar it cannot turn into form of money
because because then I could just sell
it people who want to buy it because
they can do anything with it if this
cannot do it in the form of money then
it seems to argue in the same way that
other cryptocurrencies should also not
turn into matter because they're just
worse than this one they don't even have
this basic and also there's yeah that's
a good point
although there's another point is like
what we want to prevent is that you're
currently you're currently here before
the ICO and there's nobody on your
platform right and you want to cook you
want to kind of really just shift from
one equilibrium to another equilibrium
over in which everybody going so a lot
of times like either token when it's
first launched it really has very
limited use over time it makes it become
like gained a lot of use outside a
platform if it's possible but at that
time you you guys are already now on a
good equilibrium right so that kind of
you can think about the really the role
of having the theory
it applies to the entire game but what's
most important is after at the beginning
of video yes so usually if you have a
point it's a medium of exchange you
might send it to somebody for a service
maybe see
coin is truly a utility token you're not
actually sending it to someone you're
potentially burning it as a fee right
has some watchings and the fees to it
you can think about that as kind of the
participation cost of youth somewhere
here just like whether your your
transaction goes through or not whether
you actually get the service or not you
just gonna it's called something or some
cost about this base no I understand
what is that money doesn't what if the
token gets consumed instead of going to
Bob like what are the blockchain itself
oh so then it would be kind of a
different model like because I mean
saying I'm saying that it's like some of
the platforms we can we can understand
why tokens have used for those platforms
but I'm not saying that all I SEOs are
supporting platforms I let look like
this example I think like like like
decentralized storage would be like an
example
all right so and actually this kind of
forward induction arguments right you
can just actually go one step ahead and
you can see that just that we can
sustain a efficient coordination that
every period the difficulty comes from
like what if like there is not so far
like it hears there's one player on each
side what if there are multiple players
on on both sides so this I'm gonna skip
that like we do some some discussions
about how we could extend the model in
our favor so if there's any Quinta no
questions I'm gonna for jump to the
final thing I'm gonna talk
okay so the final project is as I said
when I originally did this is not
actually intended for Bitcoin or
blockchain
but as later on I figure out okay
actually may have some some implications
there the idea is that okay we believe
that in the in the startup space or just
a consumer space right there's this
concept so called wisdom of the crowd
the collective opinion of a large group
of individuals is often found to
dominate the judgment of a single expert
if you can source opinions from a lot of
people you would long to do you would
like to do that
and why does it exist right simple law
of large number argument because
everybody has some idiosyncratic noise
in their assessment if you combine them
you can cancel them out now the question
is okay if we are talking about
investing in a project how can we best
harness this collective wisdom and this
is what we want to do and we the
solution that we provide its quoting
quote is going to be some contracting
solutions I quote it call it smart
contract it's not really smart in our
familiar sense so as long as we
understand this example we can in
standar stand this entire paper it's
very simple example to investors that is
involved they are participate they are
participating in funding a risky in a
scalable project so they independent
decide on how much money to commit to
the project and when they commit to when
they decide on how much money to put
into this project right so they
basically do their optimal return and
risk trade-off and it we assume that the
players are deep pocketed so there's no
financial financing constraints so
basically how much money you put in is
really just a trade-off between your
return and your risk and both investors
they have some private information about
what the return of the project is and
because near so-called the wisdom of a
crowd so if the players they can update
you to investors Alice and Bob they can
talk to each other before making their
investment decisions and gather cheap
source of information then both of them
will be able to make more informed
decisions suppose that you're so for
whatever reason maybe just in a very
decentralized world there's some problem
that they cannot really truthfully can
their private information is there a way
for us to divide the payoff from their
joint investment so that we can also
replicate the effect of direct
communication so this is the kind of
dissolution that we're trying to try the
question that we try to answer and the
solution will be a specific type of
contract that we that we can write and
we can now talk about okay whether this
type of contract will have any
implications for designing I SEOs or for
designing ducks any questions on the on
the other question no we're trying to
again
or the typical solution with which I
will call a common stock is that if we
make a joint investment then let's
divide our payoff in proportion to the
amount of money that we only originally
commit if Alice has invested more than
Alice should get a larger share that's
what we call common stock question is is
this really optimal and and I have an
alternative proposal that if the only
difference between Alice and Bob is
their private information I propose that
may be the optimal contracting solution
for Alice did buy the project payoff is
for them to equally divide the project
payoff I'm going to show you why this is
the case and I call this profit sharing
if there are better terms I would
welcome suggestions so so far I call
this equal sharing as a profit sharing
contract just to make it very concrete
what do i exactly mean suppose that
there is a project and when and it turns
out the return of the project's ten
percent it at is investable invests in
$200 in Bob invests in $100 then
according to this traditional common
stock assumption everybody's payoff is
going to be proportional to their
initial original investment so then
Alice will be entitled to two thirds of
the prasada there the proceeds and Bob
entitled to one-third of the proceeds
paddle investment 200 plus one hundred
that's 300 return is ten percent so the
total eventually we get the project
returns three hundred and thirty two
thirds of it Alice gets to 220 and Bob
gets one hundred and ten so now let's
say what if Alice and Bob equally
divided your payoff suppose that Alice
and Bob still invest in two hundred and
one hundred in the project the net
payoff from the project is going to be
right 200 plus three hundred one hundred
multiplied by ten ten percent that is
$30 so when I say equal divide that I
mean that they equally divided this net
payoff so what Alice gets back is her
original investment which is two hundred
plus one half of that $30 so Alice gets
back 115 I'm sorry 215 and Bob gets back
150 and this is what I mean by a
equal sharing contract if you stare at
this you're gonna ask if I'm Alice why
would I prefer this than this right in
traditional equity contract I can get
back 220 now I can only get back 215 it
looks like a very silly deal for Alice
but here is that we are making a
restriction is that when the contract
changes among Alice and Bob we assume
the optimal investment amount for them
it also doesn't change but in reality
that is not the case actually this
refers to when I my previous talk about
the the mining close we said okay if we
join a pool you are red or protected for
your risk then you should be willing to
put in more money into mining here is
also the case if we have a 50/50 sharing
contract among our payoffs both inform
Alice and Bob's perspective both
investors are better protected for their
risk so this should be willing to put in
more money into this project so if we
look at the optimal investment mount for
Alice then it like by a 50/50 rule Alice
should actually be entitled to a small
smaller piece of a larger pie which
turns out to be actually still better
than Alice yes another downside they
would both lose the same amount as well
that's right Bob is totally whoa
then then he's probably wiped out Bob
Colin is $100 Alice could lose more than
hundred dollars so you're asking me the
limited liability here yeah I'm getting
away from the net to liability
illustration under common stock if you
invest your investment is 200 and 100
the in this here's is a 50-50 sharing
the project goes by 10 percent this is
how the traditional equity contract is
going to give you and this is what the
profit sharing contract is going to give
you assuming that the optimal investment
amount doesn't change just giving it one
slide and if we but if we take the
optimal investment mount under the
profit sharing then on average both
Alice and Bob will invest more so in
this case Alice will be entitled to a
smaller piece of a larger pie which
turns out to be unknown
on average risk adjusted will be larger
than
the payoff that she gets from from here
yes so what is your investment size even
mean if you get rid of limited liability
I mean if Alice and Bob if I was putting
200 Bob put in 100 and each can lose a
million dollars in it or each can make a
million dollars like what why does it
matter what your initial investments are
the origin initial investment just how
much money that we put into this project
but since you can lose more than that
anyway you're effectively exposing
yourself to unlimited liability so it's
not yeah it's not really how much money
you put into the project you can say
that you can say that that's like if you
join a partnership firm that's basically
like that outcomes like
whoa what's a scenario in which it
matters how much I put into the into the
firm into the investment under yours so
if suppose that like the project return
is ten percent right if you originally
put in a lot of money into this that
means that 10 percent is gonna apply to
a large chunk of money also if it's lost
then also applies to a large chunk of
mine it's like you only commit a very
small amount of money that would ever
return just only operates that aren't
down that very small amount of money
there's two things that matter it's like
how big the overall bet is and then what
the return is in a percentage so you're
saying like whether I invest a hundred
or a thousand dollars or whether the
total plugs a hundred or a thousand were
sort of equally lengthening at a ten
percent win or a 10 percent loss and so
it's almost like it's not really like
putting in money it's like you you're
just choosing how big the back could be
so in a weird way like if you put in a
dollar and I could put in a million
dollars and then if a thing goes down by
ten percent you've just lost $100,000
that you're actually like increasing
other people's liability by it's very
weird but from my perspective in
expectation I should be better off
partnering with you because I believe
again it's game theory so I believe you
are rational the reason why you're
willing to put in $100 or 1 million
dollars is you have either very good
signal order so you are very confident
about your signal and so basically most
likely you're gonna win the bet because
otherwise it will be silly for you to
put in a million commits a million
dollars too so there are some smart
slight chance I'm gonna be completely
screwed up but on average I'm happy that
you actually I type the kind of joint
force with you I could do let's say I
think it's a really good bet
then I should mount the civil attack and
join a million
no not really actually there are so this
record actually is a very easy very
common thing to think about but actually
so what goes on is if you about your
Sybil attack you basically divide your
wealth in half so you're you're
basically the risk aversion of each of
your clone now is going to be different
so the optimal share that you want to
have in the pie will be different
actually like we can show that like
there's it's kind of civil resistance
there's you can do Sybil attack but
isn't make any difference to you it
could be them on my optimal share of the
product face isn't one out of em and
investors just variously I would say
like what I really want it's like
one-third so the the general result is
there if I have n investors and each of
them has risk aversion row I then your
share should be basically the inverse
your risk aversion we call risk
tolerance should be your share of your
total risk tolerance so in the example I
gave you earlier is that it was seem
that both of them are equally reverse
the only difference is there is their
information then equal sharing is good
for them but here is that the sharing
rule should be dependent on your
discovery the risk aversion parameter
just is like the curvature of York
roughly speaking as your curvature of
your utility curve
but it seems like it's almost like two
separate questions and how many tickets
do you want and how much one did you
want to park in this organization's bank
account mm-hmm and you could almost like
just separate those questions you're
saying right now like you buy shares and
that's fun the bank would just fund it
if like you have shares yes it survives
it because you can think about you know
one way to think about okay about have a
portfolio I kind of diversify against
whatever risk to the individual risk of
each investment however the source of
the risk here comes from the fact that
we actually don't know what the were the
actual return the distribution of the
return is we each other the US has a
private information somehow useful and
the kind of the risk sharing benefit
comes from kind of cancelling all the
noises in everybody's information about
the return of that one stock rather than
like the divers are buying about their
risk of all the other stocks so another
way to think about is like if you think
this instead of thinking about this as a
individual investment project think
about this as a portfolio and all the
idiosyncratic risks will be cancelled
out and only systematic risk will be
remained and you can think about that
like the information that we have or the
noise that we face is our Indus in a
noise in the our assessment about what
is systemic risk would be
how good I'm time
I'll have ten minutes oh that's more
than I that's more than I thought okay
but then and then I can well then let's
entertain some map there's nothing new
just formalizing what I have just said
right to investors they have a utility
function that captures their risk
aversion and they are investing in the
project each of them have a private
signal investor I have the private
signal si which is the return true
return plus some idiosyncratic noise and
it was incredible
we assume that it follows a normal
distribution it doesn't have to be I
purchased for the simplicity let's
assume that the formal forms a normal
distribution one thing is that okay what
if Alice Alice and Bob they invest in
so-called common stock then common stock
basically says okay
you your your payoff is basically solely
dependent on how much you have invested
in so you look at your investment
outcome coming out of this and you take
the expected utility when you take the
expectation the only source that you can
information that you can conditional on
is what private information you have and
you can easily solve this you can solve
this expression and can find that okay
the optimal investment amount should be
a weighted sum of what the unconditional
mean of the return of the return of the
project and my private signal and there
are going to be weighted by what what is
that preciseness of the the true return
and the preciseness of my information if
my information is very precise this term
will be large right I will be more
reliant on my private information and of
course everything is going to be
normalized by how risk-averse I am
what is tell are here how is the
precision of part the precision of the
unconditional precision of the precision
is base 81 are just inverse of the
variance of the return itself the return
follows a distribution and this is the
inverse of the variance of your private
information you see if this goes up that
means the variance of your risk aversion
is very small you're going to be more
reliant on your private information
what if just nice as a benchmark right
what if Addison Bob can talk to each
other if Addison Bob can talk to each
other but each investor you're still
solving the same problem but we take the
expected utility the orgonite now could
be conditional on two signals you can
also very easily solve that and you find
out the optimal investment under that
scheme would be the weighted sum of also
the unexpected the unconditional mean
and both signals and they're going to be
weighted by the precision of both
signals they can talk to each other then
this like you know omen things about you
can't we cannot agree to disagree so
eventually if they communicate they'll
eventually have the same prior right
well and that's that doesn't really
apply here because you can think about
the Alice and Bob here there's like your
we'd say there are two players but you
actually think you think I think about
there are three players right the
another player is that whoever as
actually providing this investment
opportunity nature in nature you can't a
by nature or just like an entrepreneur
who is selling this part
yes
so now this interesting case and also
where that's where the game theory if
you can begin to kick in so if I cannot
talk to each other but I have this
so-called sharing contract with others
then when I decide on how much my want
to invest not only I my payoff not only
depends on how much I invest but also
depends are like what the other person
invests which is in turn is going to be
a function about what their private
information is and when I take the
expect when I calculate the expected
utility I also need to conditional are
my only conditional on my own
information so what I'm gonna do so here
the own my information enters my
expectation in two ways first is going
to help me decide on what the return of
the project is and also is going to give
me some guidance about what the other
pile the other person is going to invest
so it's the solution will be again a
Nash equilibrium we are talking about
game theory the Nash equilibrium under
this contract would be I have a correct
belief about what the other person is
going to invest based on your signal and
face and I once I have based on that
belief I'm gonna choose what's my
optimal investment amount and in
equilibrium my counterparties optimal
investment will coincide with my belief
about what you're gonna do it is not
Nash equilibria it can solve this Nash
equilibrium though they're they're more
sophisticated to do this but just for
simplicity because previously we said
okay without this contract my optimal
investment amount should be just be a
weighted sum of the prior and just an
unconditional mean of the return and my
private signal so I just like let's say
let's assume that okay in there in this
game the solution also follows that form
and I just take undetermined
coefficients and then plug into the
optimization problem and try to solve
what the optimal solution would be and
once we get the solution then we can
compare the solutions here so under a
so-called profit sharing contract that I
just prescribed the ultimate investment
for amount for this guy is again is
going to be a weighted sum of the
unconditional mean and my private signal
and also it's going to be weighted by my
risk aversion however you can see here
is an double - and this is the concept
that we talked about before once I have
a profit sharing contra with the other
person I'm I'm effectively better
insured against the mistakes in my
private information because my private
information is noisy so I know that
sometimes I make it make a mistake
because I'm risk aversion I mean not
fully listen to my information but now I
know there's someone who can shoulder
the risk for me I can be more sensitive
to my own information so that's why my
investment becomes more sensitive to my
information so both players is going to
do that and because we know that because
of wisdom of the crowd although our
information are noisy but in average all
these information do carry some value if
in aggregate all investors become more
infor and more responsive to their
private information than the arrogate
investment amount won't just be more
informed so that is going to like to
improve the capital allocator allocation
so and and another thing that comes out
of this is that if you look at the
payoff from each individual investors
coming from this we can see that the
payoff that they get it looks like this
for and if we compare if we compare the
the benchmark we had before it's just
like if Alice and Bob can directly
communicate communication or communicate
with each other
the payoff they get is exactly the same
so another way we can say think about
this is like just the having this
contract even though whenever it's
completely difficult for the investors
to talk to each other in the aggregate
your information we can have a contract
solution to teach you to do that right I
think this contract is pretty smart and
but you know I don't have the trademark
so I don't play me the smart contract
is it are there any questions on this so
general case okay so now let's talk
about implications when I first get this
result right what just the question
would be okay I was actually thinking
about crowdfunding what will be the
optimal contract and there's no
consensus in academia study about what's
the optimal contract commonly that
equity or a hybrid of debt and equity
are also used so I think we at least
provide a solution based on an
information aggregation perspective I'm
not saying that all there are other
channels that we do not need to think
about but I securely from an information
aggregation perspective this sharing
contract quoting postmark contract seems
like a pretty good solution and it's
very easy to implement and also it
really captures this wisdom the crowd
because typically witness say okay when
you think while you do at ico or you're
doing a crowdfunding from the
entrepreneurs perspective what is wisdom
and crowd mean here is that you are
basically aggregating information from
all the users so you kind of have a
better idea about what it demand for
your product or what it demand for this
particular project is so it's the
private information from the investor
side that is benefiting from benefiting
the entrepreneurs which is important
however what we have here is that the
investors who have who themselves have
information now just through this
contracting form they can actually
benefit each other from benefit from
each other's private information so
there they bring the crowd of the wisdom
they also now they also enjoy the wisdom
among themselves and because they can
also improve capital allocation if you
are an entrepreneur has a good project
this means that on average write more
money is going to be invested to you it
just improves the capital allocation
across the entire entire market space
I'm gonna skip some of those those
furballs your bus there isn't those
results right just like say okay what if
the returned is not random what if the
information you have to acquire the
information with some cost what if the
the project is not constant returns to
scale the result will hold so I think I
would just leave it here we think about
I think about ICO is really kind of like
doing doing crowdfunding on the
blockchain so I think nothing here I
said cannot be applied to to to I cos
and actually as a matter of fact right
because in a blockchain space we can
more easily write more flexible
contracts and we can have better
enforcement of some of the like more
innovative contract forms so I think
there should be a lot of views about
potential about this kind of this new
solution to say decentralized autonomous
organization or initial point operate
this the implications is something that
we need to further think about yes
locking don't do unlimited liability
well that's correct so near once one
solution one way to get out of this cuz
uh one way to get out of this is that
there's one robustness result that I
said okay I don't have to assume
everything is is normal so if it can you
be nobody is a normal distribution yeah
you can always have unlimited
realizations but this result actually is
more general than just normal so you if
you restrict your attention to some but
founded distributions then you can
potentially avoid this but it is true
that like if you invest a small amount
of money into the project it doesn't
necessarily mean that okay your loss
will always be small that's that's true
but it could be avoided that just like
your your your your loss is like
unlimited that can be that can be that
is this in the model that it doesn't
exist in reality
so I think so that way this all these
stuff right you can just find it all the
papers online so by the end just like we
have constant now not what I'm trying to
do that today is trying to look at those
consensus protocols and and typically as
an economist as we do write a game
theory we assume everybody to be
rational whether that's a good
assumption or not that's another
question but like we tend to get used to
that framework
well you look at those consensus
protocols we all lose the exhaustion
this assume that some video some people
are malicious
some people are resident in that some
people are honest and we found that like
very not particularly satisfied with
that so actually we're trying to do
something that puts these contentious
particles into the rational framework
turns out to be very difficult to do so
I'm still working on that i I wish I
could talk about them more about this
but that's all that can happen so I'm
trying to imagine just to kind of like
make it more intuitive is this seem so
weird
if I were to try to like do actually
implement this would it be would want
one way to do this would this be an
implementation of this idea we're doing
a startup company and so the stock is
free like anyone can have as much common
stock as they want but but you're
subject to you have to be like show that
you have collateral that you can support
the liability and then we only fund with
debt but there's no there's bonds that
don't pay any interest but the reason
you would want to you'd the reason we'd
want to buy these bonds is because you
own because you signed up with some
stock and therefore you want the company
to do something I mean let me try to
piece everything together so you said I
only only Fon done first throw bonds the
question of how much can one eat it dump
in this company now completely
independent from what fraction of the
profit or loss do I want right yes if
now complete independent but it's
attached to to certain extent I can sign
up for stock and the stock is free it's
just exposed to be the liability or get
it yes so yes actually you can think
about this
that's a good point I it's kind of have
some you can implement it with some
combination of bond and securities
because you can write you can see what
this is like pure equity and here's how
has some bond features in it you combine
them and and yes and and I think your
point about like the kind of what I'm
actually eventually potentially
committed to the project and versus like
how much exposure of the of the just a
surplus or loss from the project could
be detached it's kind of like the same
so the one thing that this so this
actually makes sense but then the thing
that it seems to be missing compared to
the traditional model which I've done is
this scarcity that there's often this
like feeding frenzy of venture
capitalists who and like because is you
know you have a five person startup
that's gonna grow to be a hundred people
whatever you can't necessarily spend a
billion dollars right so there's only so
much investment you can take and often
people actually take the most expensive
money they can get this you know then
you get access to some better rolodex
but still a this idea of it like it may
be that there's more money then you can
actually put to productive use and
therefore yulux you'll use that to
extract the premium from the scarcity of
your stock so that's now missing from
this model is that some weird artificial
thing or is there something is that a
fundamentally something that makes
- like the company should be able to
leverage the scarcity of the investment
to carry a premium charge that's a good
point
I think about a solution offline yeah
okay and an answer offline I think seems
to be make sense but I did double-check
I don't want to say anything that I'm
not sure
let's thank the speaker and take a break
[Applause]
so I'm trying to understand the last
comment that you said